Oh
okay so we'll get started next speaker
is Peter King talking about data
assimilation thank you it's a pleasure
to be here I'm going to be talking today
about data assimilation for discrete
event simulation so I'm going to explain
what data assimilation is I'll explain
what discrete event simulation czar and
this is a problem that turns out to be
quite closely connected to what in the
simulation world is called the startup
problem or the warm-up problem which in
the context of steady state or
equilibrium simulations or Markov chain
Monte Carlo relates to the question of
how long to run a Markov chain sampler
in order to begin picking up samples
from the equilibrium distribution in
this context we're not going to be
looking at equilibrium simulation we're
going to be looking at transient
simulations so the startup problem
arises in a quite different context here
historically I think with into the
discrete event simulation world at least
many people have viewed transient
simulations and startups issues
associated with that as being in some
sense trivial but I think you'll see
today that in fact there are quite a few
subtleties associated with how you
initialize simulations in this transient
setting so I'm going to be talking about
start-up issues and I should say at the
outset that this is also a startup talk
in a different sense you'll see that
there are lots of open issues here so in
some sense what we're doing here is
starting up the research agenda on this
class of problems there are plenty of
things to do plenty of things to think
about in this context so first of all
what's data assimilation so for people
that do weather prediction this is a
major issue so many of the mathematical
algorithms that are used to predict
weather are based on PDE based
circulation models and these PDE
simulations need to be initialized and
so you need to initialize with an
appropriate initial condition and the
challenge is that the data that is
collected for weather is assimilated for
many different sources
there are all kinds of subtleties
associated with assimilating from these
different sources for example different
different meteorology stations collect
data at different times of the day so
you don't necessarily get a common
initial point at which all the data is
being gathered you have issues with
regard to integrating satellite data
integrating weatherstrip data there's
lots of different challenges associated
with creating an appropriate initial
condition for these PDE solvers so we
talked a little bit about discrete event
simulation now let me say a little bit
about discrete event simulation so
discrete event simulation ZAR dynamic
simulation simulations of dynamic
systems in which we are tracking
discrete entities within the system so
these would be things like customers
pieces of inventory pieces of assembled
product within a production system these
might be passengers within a
ride-sharing platform the vehicles
themselves we're talking about
simulating these types of systems and
sort of generically speaking the types
of simulations that all of these
different applications fall underneath
as an umbrella term is the class of
discrete event simulation so
prototypical example of discrete event
simulation is the single server q single
server q with infinite capacity waiting
room first-come first-serve
and if you think about the way that
these systems are typically simulated so
if you look at a discrete event
simulation package usually the way that
these discrete event simulation --zz
will evolve in time from a algorithmic
standpoint is that for example at time T
equals 0 you'll schedule the time of the
first customer to arrive so you randomly
choose an inter arrival time according
to the inter arrival distribution
imagine that that sets a clock and now
the clock begins running down to zero at
unit speed at this time the first
customer arrives now you need to
schedule the next arrival time the next
arrival time is the solid line we also
need to schedule the next service time
that's the dotted line up here
you can see that in this particular
realization the next service time is
much larger than the next inter arrival
time now again if these clocks begin
running down to zero the next event to
occur is another arrival and you can see
here this is counting up the number of
customers in the system as a function of
time T we started off with zero
customers in system then one customer in
the system to customers and system and
so forth so a discrete event simulation
typically involves a so-called future
event schedule that may have hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands of events
sitting in this future event schedule
evolving the system forward in time
so the typical Markovian representation
for such a system if you want to make
this type of system Markov assuming that
the different clock setting
distributions for the inter arrival
times and service times are non
exponential then we need to track within
the state descriptor not just the number
of customers in the system but also the
residual time left at time T for this
clock to run down to zero so this is
thinking about discrete event systems
and discrete event simulation from the
standpoint of a discrete event
simulation package so again discrete
event simulation Packers is typically
are evolving the system forward by using
residual time representations and the
Markov state would correspond to the
number of customers in the system and
the current state of the residual time
on each of the two clocks corresponding
to nth arrival times and service times
there's an alternative Markovian
description which instead of looking at
the residual time looks at the elapsed
time how much time has passed since you
entered this state and this is a more
natural state from the standpoint of
doing statistics because at a given time
T if you observe the full state of the
system you'll know how long it has been
since you observed the last arrival so
that would be the state variable
corresponding to a elapsed time and
again you can do the same type of
calculus as we did in the context of the
residual time representation to in
principle simulate a system using this
elapsed time representation
this is never used actually within
discrete-event simulation world it's
always the residual time representations
that are used but from a mathematical
standpoint in some sense respects this
is a more natural representation it's in
this representation for example that you
get a state space collapse when you have
exponential inter arrival times an
exponential service times because the
transition mechanism for elapsed time
depends on the so called hazard rate of
the underlying random variables and in
the context of exponential random
variables the hazard rate is a constant
for those types of distributions so you
don't need to track you latch time when
you have exponential distributions from
the standpoint of this representation so
two different ways of thinking about
discrete event systems from the
standpoint of Markov process theory so
the class of discrete event simulation
is discrete event systems actually was
the study of these systems was actually
initialized or initiated a long time ago
by the East Germans already back in the
60s 70s through 80s there were many
papers that came out within that
community
later on Mark Davis independently looked
at the class a piecewise deterministic
Markov processes that is a
generalization of generalized semi
markov processes but when he did that
work I think he was unaware of the fact
that there was this connection to gsm
peas to generalize semi markov processes
so that literature basically even to
this day has largely disconnected from
this gsm pea world in terms of thinking
about discrete event simulation again
there are two types of Markovian
representations that we can think about
in this context the residual time markov
process the elapsed time markov process
and both of these processes exhibit
interesting recurrence behavior and
various other nice theoretical
properties at least in the context of
finite physical state space so the
physical state space is basically
tracking two discrete at a decent system
the C of T is the state variable
corresponding to the clocks and that
typically would be continuous
so let me tell you a little bit now
about a problem context that I was
exposed to a few years ago at a major
automaker they were interested in
looking at better management of their
fleet wide containers the containers are
the things that basically carry pirates
like engines and sub assemblies from one
assembly plant to another and you really
can't ship these things without
containers because if you try to do that
you're probably going to break the
components break the engine there'll be
all kinds of damage that will be
sustained so you you need to have these
containers in the context of this
automaker the inventory corresponding to
containers is the order of many billions
of dollars it's non-trivial expense for
the auto maker and it's pretty clear
that the factories that they have should
have to shut down if they run out of
inbound supplies the inbound containers
it also turns out that they've been a
sickly need to shut down if they don't
have outbound containers to ship their
engines and various other parts out so a
key issue in this context is you want to
avoid shortages at the different
factories that happens you basically
have to shut the factory down so
extremely high cost if you run out of
containers at a factory so you need to
manage these containers as effectively
as possible that means that there are
going to be situations coming up
constantly at which maybe in real time
you want to do some reallocation of
where these containers are flowing to so
this is a context of real-time decision
making and this was basically the issue
that the car maker wanted to address was
to build a platform where you could look
at trying to do what if analysis related
to this type of real-time decision an
important thing to recognize is that
certainly in that year and I think
probably even today very few of these
containers have digital tags so if they
had digital tags then you'd be able to
put it at least in principle track all
the different container
a system you'd know where they all are
but in fact I think even today you don't
have individual tagging on the on the
containers what you have is that the
containers go through transshipment
points and when they go through the
transshipment point then somebody takes
the barcode off the container and then
you know where that particular container
is at that time there's a situation
where you don't have full state
information with regard to where the
containers are you only have partial
state information this is the data
simulation issue that I was referring to
earlier in the talk specialized in a
particular context all right so what we
have again from a discrete event
simulation standpoint is a GS MP Markov
process again corresponding to the
physical state of discrete entities and
the clock variables and now we I think
recognize that even if the model only
looks at the larger and more valuable
and more expensive types of containers
that are in the system the number of
different containers in the potential
number of different configurations in
which these containers can be spread
across the system as a whole can be
humongously large so s of T this
discrete part of the state space has
very very large cardinality and what
does the observe a bully observable is
well at time T we don't get to observe
anything about the clocks at all but we
actually don't get to observe the
physical state of the system where all
the discrete entities are either because
of this transcript man issue so
abstracting things away to some degree
what we really observe there's a process
Z of T corresponding to some
deterministic map taking the physical
entities and mapping them into some much
lower dimensional observable right so
for example might be instead of tracking
where all the different individual
containers are it might tell you you
have this many containers in flow from
this particular transshipment point to
this particular transshipment point on a
bun
of other piece of the state information
along those lines so the function K is
typically significantly collapsing the
physical state variable s of T now what
we'd like to do is we'd like to make
some decision let's say about the system
here's current time we know that the
system is exhibiting some worrisome
characteristics let's say with regard to
it looks to us like it may be that one
of our factories or assembly points is
going to run out of containers in the
next next couple of days and we'd like
to begin thinking about doing some
what-if analysis the what-if analysis
corresponds to here's current time we'd
like to understand something about the
system tea time it's in the future let's
say T is equal to two days into the
future so we'd like to compute let's say
some measure of how starved of
containers the system is at time S Plus
T given the history of the observables
up to time s up to current time so it's
clear to everybody what the problem is
so you want to compute this conditional
expectation conditional on the history
so because of the fact that the state
process X that we simulate with is
Markov we can write this conditional
expectation given in the history in
terms of conditional expectation given
the state variable at time s being equal
to some given value X then we have to
integrate over the uncertainty and the
state variable given the conditioning on
the observables so at some level if we
could sample from this conditional
distribution from the conditional
distribution of the state at time s
given the observables up to time s we'd
be in good shape
because once we have that we could
sample from this and let me just
simulate the process forward and time
from time s prime s plus T look at this
random variable Y replicate that a few
times and that will give us an estimate
of the conditional expectation
course this is a filtering problem it's
a hard filtering problem and so I'm
gonna tell you what the filter looks
like for this class of processes it's
even a bigger mess than what you see for
Markov jump processes and this is
basically the filter evolution for the
random measure corresponding to the
distribution of the system at time T
over physical states and over clock
variables so this is a density in C a
distribution over s primed and C
depending on T and of course it depends
on the observables that you've seen up
to time s so it's a random measure
that's evolving forward in time based on
the observables that one sees and you
can see some partial derivatives in here
this corresponds to the fact that the
clocks are running up in time
deterministically at unit rate that has
to do with the fact that in this
particular that the natural way to think
about the filtering of this context is
in terms of the elapsed time
representation so the clock values are
running up in time as time proceeds up
to the time of a jump and you can see
also that this evolution is nonlinear
you can see here we've got some
quadratic terms and the V and the new on
both the on the right hand side here and
that reflects the fact that the filter
needs to constantly renormalize itself
so that it has probability mass what you
can also see here these are the hazard
rates for the clocks and these would
simplify significantly when you have
exponential clocks for example in the
system
now where does the randomness come from
in this evolution everything here is
evolving deterministically the
randomness shows up at the times that
the observable switches state and so
there's a different update obviously at
the jump times of Z of T so I'm not
gonna write that down it's another big
mess so the main point here is big mess
and another big mess and again you know
in terms of types of seeming types of
systems we're thinking about we're
really thinking about systems that are
really evolving in very very high
dimensional spaces number of clocks is
going to be in the order of hundreds and
the physical configuration space for the
physical state is also going to have
enormous cardinality you can also derive
filtering equations for the residual
time Markov process but I won't talk
about that and so the challenges here is
we have a very very high dimensional
filter there's also an issue in the
transition density of this system is
intractable so many of the particle
filtering algorithms assume that you
have some density information yeah
basically none of that available for
this class of systems a particular
mathematical challenge in this context
that you don't typically see in most
settings in which filters are applied is
that for example if you have if you're
thinking about a system it has three
different clocks that are simultaneously
running and one of the clocks
transitions is triggered in some way the
other two clocks will of course whatever
Delta there was between the other two
clocks will be preserved after that
transition occurs and that means that
there's a sort of lack of absolute
continuity in the transition structure
for this class of models that you don't
see in typical for example diffusion
processes or other Markov process
contexts
so these mathematical challenges with
regards to
transition structure of these systems
some singularities that are career that
make filtering this context particularly
challenging so I'm practical filtering
is highly non-trivial in this context I
certainly don't know how to do it and so
what we're gonna do instead is something
much simpler but something that has
still got significant mathematical
challenges associated with it as we'll
see
so rather than conditioning on the
entire past trajectory of the
observables let's just throw away all of
that state information except for the
current state of the observable so again
in the context of the container problem
that would be we have all the current
information from that comes in from the
different transshipment points but we're
gonna throw away all of the prior
information and the dynamics of what's
been happening historically at the
transshipment points so I think in a lot
of many applications that's not an
unreasonable thing to do if it makes the
problems they've never going to be more
tractable so let's suppose for example
that in the system that we are
interested in doing a real-time
simulation for the current state of the
system is Z head so we really like to do
now is we'd like to know what is the
conditional distribution of the
underlying Markov state given that the
observable takes on this value C hat so
this is a simple thing to answer if this
probability isn't too small
this probability isn't too small we can
do lots of simulations up to time s up
to current time s look at the
simulations on which the value of the
observable on that particular path is
equal to the current state of the
observable and just average in some
pseudo pale way relative to that
another thing that you can do in this
context is something called splitting so
once we get one of these physical one of
these Markov states that's compatible
with the current value of the observable
we can now do a whole bunch of
conditionally independent simulations up
to time T and average out over those
things this is called splitting we're
doing conditionally independent
simulations given the state that we've
simulated the Markov state dually
simulated at time s and then we got an
estimator of this kind now you can
optimize over the value of M there's
lots known about how to construct good
splitting algorithms in this context a
more challenging issue and one that I
think is more typical of at least as
container context is what do you do when
this probability is actually smooth so
when you do these forward simulations up
to current time s you actually pick up
almost no simulation there may be no
simulations at all that match the
current configuration at the of how the
containers are spread out across the
transshipment points so what do you do
in this case so what you do in this case
and natural thing to think about doing
in this case is to maybe apply some
ideas similar to what one does in the
context of density estimation treating
the discrete variables as being sort of
continuous basically doing some local
averaging in which we look at the
simulations that we do we look at the
value of the observable and a
particularly simulation i simulation
that we do and look at how close that is
to the actual current observed values
ehed and then we do some appropriate
weighting based on how close the
simulated value of Zi of S is for that
trajectory relative to the actual
observed value Z hat in the current
underlying real world system
and the smooth and Colonel Roe when you
can choose to this will have various
moving parameters contained within it
and you can imagine for example choosing
those smoothing parameters using
principles similar to what one does in
continuous case and why would one
imagine doing that well for people that
do a lot of stochastic modeling there
are things known as fluid limits that
can be derived for many systems of this
kind in which the number containers for
example is allowed to go to infinity
according to some limit operation and in
those types of fluid limit contexts it's
reasonable to approximate the discrete
system by a continuous system and you're
basically drawing upon some sort of
limit theorem of that kind so one thing
I haven't talked about here is the need
to simultaneously estimate the
underlying model parameters I've assumed
all the dynamics are known but of course
that's never true in reality so
important question is to think about how
to do that and these also have some
other interesting things that you can do
in this context relate it to the
probability of assessing the model error
in other words the simulation model
error based on what you see in the real
world y of S Plus T relative what you
get from the simulations so that's what
also an intriguing possibility in terms
of things that you can potentially do
that would be hard to do in a pure
statistical context where you can't draw
up on a simulation model to potentially
calibrate and assess the model here so
inclusions just read event simulation I
think well I gave you the container
example but there are lots of other
settings in which I think as we go
forward in time there'll be more and
more opportunity use simulation as a
real time decision-making tool standard
thing that will occur when you try to
use simulation as a real time
decision-making tool is steady state
simulations will not be pertinent you'll
have to think about the current state of
the system and how that influences the
dynamics over the decision horizon in
question when you do that there's
typically going to be a big mismatch but
in a mathematical state that underlies
the discrete-event simulation model and
the actual physical observable so that
you see in the real world and we can see
that even when you simplify this problem
to looking at the conditional
distribution of the Markov State given
the current value of the observable that
there's some non-trivial and interesting
computational mathematical questions to
be addressed so thank you I don't think
so right so that would be a way of
dealing with the clock part of the state
space but I think actually it's probably
the clocks typically are not the primary
influence on what happens for example in
this container context t-time innocent
of future the biggest issue is not
knowing the actual physical
configuration of the discrete entities
in the system and that's the that won't
be solved by using I mean it's a nice
idea to use things like phase type
distributions
you could have started from that state
that's an interesting idea I haven't
thought about that I don't like I mean I
at one time I did think about what the
time reversal of a GS MP looks like and
it wasn't an easy object to work with
okay is it easy to incorporate if the
probability distribution itself was
changing like you know right so
everything that I did here actually was
dealing with the simple case where the
distributions are assumed to be
invariant relative to time of day of
course in real systems and in
particularly types of systems that maybe
we really want to be thinking about
these distributions for example into
rival distribution various other
characteristics of that type actually
depend on time of day so they're
actually additional parameters that
would be floating around in that filter
that makes the problem even more
complicated than what I've stated here
thank you very much
[Applause]